le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
né en 1989 le conseil départemental des
jeunes fêtera ses 30 ans l'an prochain
trente années qui ont permis à une
succession de collégiens de faire
entendre leur voix sur différents sujets
retour sur cette assemblée qui montre
que la politique n'est pas une affaire
d'âge c'est un vent de fraîcheur qui
souffle dans l'hémicycle il est temps
pour les membres du conseil
départemental des jeunes de faire le
bilan de l'année écoulée élu président
en novembre 2010 est victor 15 ans pour
son rôle très à coeur
alors mon rôle en tant que président
c'est d'être le porte parole de la
jeunesse réunionnaise
donc je vais faire des actions tout au
long de ma mandature qui va durer un an
avec le bureau et les jeunes personnel
départementaux sur des causes qui me
tiennent à coeur en tant que jeunes une
expérience enrichissante et positive
pour le jeune homme qui en ressort
grandi
ça m'a appris et dans le monde phase
puisque j'ai pris de la confiance en moi
je vais plus vers les gens alors
qu'avant voilà j'avais des difficultés à
aller j'avais un peu peur du jugement
comme tout le monde en tant que jeune
voilà c'est comme ça
et justement le conseil départemental
déjà nîmes a appris à aller à l'est
envers tout le monde à sourire a
vraiment profiter de chaque seconde
puisque chaque minute chaque seconde est
précieux une détermination et une envie
d'oeuvrer à l'amélioration de la société
qui coïncide avec l'ambition du cdj
offrir aux jeunes puissent de
responsabilité et les moyens de changer
les choses assez leur faire prendre
conscience dans le cadre de la
démocratie participative de pouvoir
s'exprimer de ne pas avoir peur d'eux
d'être face à un public et surtout
d'apprendre aussi à mettre en place des
projets des projets comme cette journée
de prévention avec pour thème la
sécurité routière ce qui est important
pour nous c'est à la fin aujourd'hui
pour cette manifestation c'est de faire
comprendre aux jeunes que
enfin les veaux sont dangereuses et
qu'il faut faire attention ce protégé
par rapport à des choses qu'on ne fait
pas forcément attention la vitesse les
réglementations le code de la route et
les protections nécessaires pour ce
faire les jeunes ont pu compter sur le
soutien de la gendarmerie
alors ça fait trois années qu'on a le
plaisir d'intervenir au sein de cet
hémicycle et à chaque fois c'est c'est
très enrichissant parce que quel que
soit le message qu'on veut faire passer
on a vraiment une bonne écoute on essaye
d'être relativement vivant on essaye de
de prendre des films de les emmener un
peu telle une enquête policière pour
déterminer mais quelle quelle qu'elle
fait ont provoqué tel accident
autre lieu autre action les résidents
d'un ehpad ont eu la chance de recevoir
la visite des jeunes conseillers qui ont
passé un après-midi entier avec nous
alors nous avons choisi de faire une
action auprès des personnes âgées pour
alors apporter un peu de bonheur de qui
était avec eux pour partager un bon
moment avec eux et on s'est associé avec
une chorale et donc on a chanté tout
seul après midi avec eux et on a partagé
des moments on a parlé avec eux on a
dansé avec eux on a rigolé a vécu on a
partagé vraiment un bon moment
un moment privilégié qui a ravi jeunes
et moins jeunes
on voit bien qui dans leurs yeux qu'ils
sont heureux de voir qu'on est présents
des jeunes comme nous de venir faire la
fête avec eux et vraiment ça fait chaud
au coeur
on est juste heureux de pouvoir les
faire sourire et leur apporter un peu de
bonheur
c'est donc un bilan particulièrement
positif pour le conseil cette saison et
peut-être pour certains le début d'une
grande carrière
c'est une expérience exceptionnelle pour
moi avec le gmq même si j'ai 15 ans est
une des meilleures expériences de ma vie
et je n'oublierai jamais et que même si
oui c'est une mission où on a beaucoup
de responsabilités
je m'amuse enfin quand je dis je m'amuse
et je prends du plaisir je souris je
rigole mais je sais aussi être sérieux
et avoir des objectifs
j'aimerais faire de la politique donc je
pense que ça ne pouvait que ma portée du
plus arrivé au terme de son mandat
victor doit laisser sa place de
président du cdj un poste convoité qui
ne laisse pas ses élèves des 4e en
différentes et suite à la proposition de
mon principal en fin d'année dernière
d'être au cdj cette année j'ai tenté de
voir comment ça se passait et au bout
d'un an
j'en viens même plus nos mots pourquoi
pas essayer d'être président et de
m'investir encore plus dans pour l'aide
des élèves
moi je présente l'année prochaine parce
que tout ce que le pdci c'est une
manière de s'exprimer une manière de de
rendre un peu bas les jeunes meilleur
parce qu'on pourra faire des
interventions qui ont l'air très
excitante c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui me plaît énormément
peu importe les résultats de la future
élection ces jeunes remonterait que
leurs idées pouvaient être entendus un
pas de plus vers le monde des adultes et
ses responsabilités
ce sont des jeunes qui est vraiment
prennent part ils ont tous leur mot à
dire
ils n'ont pas peur et c'est de ça dont
on a besoin c'est des jeunes qu'ils
puissent prendre demain leur avenir en
main
[Musique]
le conseil départemental des jeunes
permet aux collégiens de faire entendre
leur voix et d'organiser des actions
concrètes
ces actions ont trait à quatre domaines
la solidarité la culture et le sport
l'éducation et la citoyenneté et
l'environnement le cdj est ouvert aux
élèves de 5e 4e et 3e sont éligibles les
délégués de chaque classe son siège est
situé au palais de la source à saint
denis
pour plus d'informations rendez-vous
www.cggveritas.com
[Musique]
monsieur k pied charles et je suis
conducteur d'engin je suis partie déjà
dans un esprit de motivation pour
trouver quelque chose voulait vraiment
parcourir la france et l'europe
justement grâce à ce métier moi et
madame ben on est parti
le week-end en prenait en zoulou et déjà
des voitures déjà à cette époque là à 20
ans et on partait à l'aventuré s'avoue
mûrit aussi ça vous donne une
perspective de la vie de vous dire que
ben si je peux être capable de rester
là-bas et d'aller prospecter à droite à
gauche pour envie de réussir voilà y'a
pas de raison que je ne réussisse part à
la réunion je me suis dit bon écoute non
je pense moi je vais retourner
on va mettre le paquet pas trouvé ce
qu'on veut chez nous voilà voilà
[Musique]